à berlin le discours du premier ministre
britannique gordon brown
et il me reste à remercier infiniment
tous nos invités d'avoir été en direct
avec nous merci de votre fidélité pour
ces éditions spéciales on retrouve tout
de suite david pujadas pour une édition
exceptionnelle de votre journal en
direct de berlin
boutonnat bunch bonsoir et bienvenue à
tous ici à berlin capitale du monde pour
cet anniversaire de la chute du mur
fêter avec éclat dans les rues malgré
une pluie battante
nous sommes vous êtes aux premières
loges devant la porte de brandebourg
là où passait le mur et là où sont
célébrés en ce moment ces commémorations
voici les titres de cette édition
spéciale
vingt ans après l'allemagne c'est donc
souvenu de ses moments d'euphorie cent
mille personnes dans les rues des
concerts un sommet de chefs d'état nous
reverrons les temps forts de cette
journée anniversaire en gala merkel a
fendu la foule en franchissant un ancien
point de passage nicolas sarkozy et
gordon brown viennent d'achever leur
discours en france rebondissement dans
la sphère du convoyeur de fonds à lyon 9
des 11 millions d'euros volés ont été
retrouvés dans un parking
loeb lui est toujours recherché nous
serons en direct à lyon une journée
éprouvante pour un million d'usagers des
rer a et b à paris comme prévu un train
sur dix et un train sur quatre seulement
ont circulé sur les deux voies attention
la grève est reconduite demain sur le
rer b
et puis on reviendra sur cette
incroyable match entre lyon et marseille
5 partout un déluge de bulles hier soir
et du grand spectacle en ligue 1
merci d'être avec nous donc pour cette
édition spéciale priorité à au direct
dans un instant ce sera tout simplement
le clou de cette soirée mille dominos de
deux mètres cinquante de haut ont été
disposés partout sur l'ancien tracé du
mur et ses mille dominos réplique
symbolique de ce mur de berlin vont
s'écrouler en cascade sous les yeux des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
attendent nous le suivrons bien sûr ici
avec nos invités
d'abord et bien le récit de cette
journée que vous avez pu vivre en direct
sur notre antenne
l'allemagne se retrouvent berlin fait
ces retrouvailles commentaires claude
sans père
c'est l'image symbole de ce vingtième
anniversaire de la chute du mur de
berlin
des centaines de jeunes qui n'ont pas
connu 1989
les jeunes qui symbolise une allemagne
réunifiée une europe libre
ils y viennent de franchir la porte de
brandebourg
derrière eux anglais la merkel la
chancellière allemande
accompagné des chefs d'état des quatre
puissances qui ont occupé l'allemagne
depuis la défaite de 1945
anguel à merkel visiblement très ému
ils sont plusieurs milliers rassemblés
sous une pluie fine par de brandebourg
pour cette journée historique
en ouverture de cette soirée de fête un
concert exceptionnel dirigée par daniel
barenboim
dans la tribune angela merkel la
chancelière allemande
nicolas sarkozy gordon brown le premier
ministre britannique
son épouse et michael gorbatchev
l'ancien numéro un soviétique sans qui
le mur ne serait jamais tomber un peu
plus loin
dimitri medvedev le président russe et
hillary clinton la secrétaire d'état
américaine
la porte de brandebourg est le symbole
de berlin
elle se trouvait dans le no man's land
du mur construit en 1961
un peu plus tôt dans l'après-midi en
gala merkel la chancellière allemande
avait franchi à pied le pont de la bonne
humeur strasser un des premiers points
de passage ouverts en 1989 entre l'est
et l'ouest
à l'époque on gueule à merkel avait 35
ans elle avait passé toute son enfance à
l'est et en novembre 1989 avec des
milliers d'est allemands
elle avait franchi ce point de passage
cet après-midi dans une jolie cohue et
l'a parcouru à pied une nouvelle fois ce
lieu symbolique valu la peine de se
battre de lutter c'est une belle journée
aujourd'hui
et s'il nous fêtons ce jour ici et ce
soir allez board brandebourg
et bien c'est un jour de fête pour tous
ceux qui rêvent aujourd'hui en russie en
europe et ailleurs
une fois de plus un grand merci à tous
à l'heure actuelle les festivités
continuent porte de brandebourg
actuellement 7
hillary clinton qui est en train de
s'exprimer derrière nous en direct
nicolas sarkozy lui vient d'achever son
discours c'était il ya quelques minutes
avec vous allez l'entendre quelques
phrases en allemand on écoute le
président de la république donc à chute
du mur de berlin théâtrale tabac
lienemann aujourd'hui comme un appel et
se feront en sorte un appel à doute tous
à combattre les oppressions à abattre
les murs qui à travers le monde
il y avait là trad'envie misera encore
des villes des territoires des peuples
voilà donc le message que l'europe
réconciliée est fière de porter et
d'incarner dans le monde
voilà pourquoi les européens ressentent
aujourd'hui dans leur coeur
ce que les berlinois chantaient au soir
du 9 novembre il y a vingt ans wir sind
brüder wir zine berline
voilà nous sommes des berlinois bonsoir
arnaud boutet vous avez suivi ces
cérémonies toute la journée vous êtes
notre correspondant ici à berlin vous
connaissez parfaitement l'allemagne dans
quel état d'esprit s'est déroulée cette
journée les allemands savaient depuis
des semaines que tous les regards
aujourd'hui sont braqués sur berlin
alors ils ont travaillé pour que cette
journée soit une fête historique
un événement exceptionnel un événement
différent de l'anniversaire des dix ans
de la chute du mur kate est quasiment
passée inaperçue
alors certes la personnalité certes le
parcours dans gala merkel y est pour
beaucoup
je me rappelle que la chancelière est
originaire de l'ex rda qu'elle a en
quelque sorte personnifié cet événement
en parlant beaucoup d'elle en parlant de
ses souvenirs
mais voilà depuis vingt ans après la
chute du mur et bien aujourd'hui
l'allemagne est bien s'exprime bien plus
volontiers sur ses réussites sur ses
échecs par rapport à la réunification et
ici on exprime aussi depuis quelques
années depuis la coupe du monde une
certaine fierté
on expose son drapeau on en a vu tout à
l'heure dans la foule le drapeau de
l'allemagne le drapeau de berlin je
crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui cette fierté
d'être allemand et cette fierté d'être
reconnu comme un acteur de l'histoire
merci arnaud cette fierté aux et cette
identité allemande
on aura l'occasion d'en parler tout au
long de cette édition spéciale alors
voici maintenant la fête côté foule il y
avait beaucoup d'allemands on l'a vu
dans la rue aujourd'hui il y avait
beaucoup aussi de familles venues de
toute l'europe et notamment de france
reportage loïc de la mornais brise
boussouar par grappes
ils se sont accrochés au montant de cet
autre rideau de fer qui était le pont
buzz bruch qui séparait l'est de l'ouest
les allemands sont venus refaire la
traversée avec angela merkel comme elle
des milliers de berlinois de l'est ont
emprunté cette première brèche vers la
liberté il y a 20 ans cette nuit là on
ne savait pas ce qui allait se passer
on se demandait si le régime ne laissait
pas partir les mauvais socialiste comme
une expulsion déguisée et s'il n'allait
pas fermé la porte derrière nous elle
était est-allemande lui venait de
l'ouest pour ce couple l'ouverture de ce
pont reste clairement le plus beau jour
de leur vie
j'ai eu le sentiment d'une grande
famille qui se retrouvaient ans à cette
réunification et comme vous pouvez
l'entendre
vingt ans après j'en ai encore la voix
qui tremble mais c'est à la porte de
brandebourg quelques heures plus tard
que la foule se rassemble
et qu'importe la pluie beaucoup de
jeunes même s'ils étaient à peine née
lors de la chute du mur ont voulu
commémorer l'événement et parmi eux
beaucoup de français on avait 10 ans
quand on a vu la chute du mur à la télé
et en foule est là aujourd'hui pour
l'anniversaire
c'est qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
patier autant que ça en fait
donc ça nous touche quand même dans un
quart d'heure un gigantesque mur humain
devrait se former dans tout berlin 33
mille personnes inscrites sur internet
sont attendus pour se tenir la main et
former ainsi un mur pacifiste mais le
mauvais temps a eu raison de certaines
bonnes volontés et à quelques minutes de
l'événement moins d'un tiers des
participants a répondu à l'appel
voilà pour ce premier compte rendu ici à
berlin dans quelques minutes
on va se retrouver pour le temps fort de
cette soirée la chute des dominos géants
en direct on va évoquer aussi ce moment
d'histoire ici on voit le signal en
direct tout simplement c'est la
chancelière angela merkel qui est en
train de clôturer à cette série de
discours des dirigeants qui sont réunis
ici on va reparler cet événement qui a
pris tout le monde par surprise
on évoquera aussi et oui une polémique
française en ce moment à propos de ce
mur de berlin et de cette journée du 9
novembre 89 avec la présence ou pas de
nicolas sarkozy sur les lieux
on verra aussi des images qu'on a peu vu
celle des journaux télévisés de l'époque
d'abord l'autre actualité de cette
journée en france et ailleurs
berlin paris c'est à vous marie drucker
bonsoir mari les autres titres de cette
journée bonsoir david bosphore berlin
ici paris bonsoir à tous
rebondissement dans la sphère du fourgon
de transport de fonds retrouvé vide
jeudi dernier à lyon la quasi-totalité
du butin dérobé a été retrouvés dans un
box l'immeuble a lyon les enquêteurs ont
récupéré 9 millions d'euros
il en reste encore un peu plus de 2 dans
la nature en revanche deux convoyeurs de
fonds disparus n'a toujours pas été
localisé benoît gadret 9 millions 105
mille euros en coupures de 5 à 100 euros
voici une grande partie du butin de ce
cas sans précédent
les paquets étaient dissimulés derrière
ce véhicule de location dans ce box un
garage situé dans un sous sol d'immeuble
à quelques centaines de mètres seulement
du lieu
le convoyeur a disparu avec l'argent les
policiers ont localisé la planque dès
vendredi soir nous avons effectué une
enquête de voisinage assez poussée des
êtres qui nous a permis de découvrir un
box qu'il avait loué ceci est l'entité
et c'était le jackpot à l'intérieur de
ce box la diffusion de la photo du
convoyeur l'examen de ces comptes
bancaires ont semble-t-il également
permis d'identifier ce lieu le box
étaient loués depuis le mois d'avril les
voisins s'interrogeaient sur cette
étrange locataires bricoler dans son
garage pour vour le porte fermée oui et
plusieurs jours de suite pendant plus de
48 heures les policiers ont surveillé le
box avec l'espoir d'interpol et toni
musulin en vain pour l'heure le
convoyeur semble avoir agi seul
c'est lui qui a loué le box c'est lui
qui a loué le véhicule c'est lui qui a
aidé par qu'avec le cabillaud toni
musulin reste ce soir en fuite avec le
reste du butin environ deux millions
cinq cent mille euros et devant l'hôtel
de police de lyon nous retrouvons
virginie fiché en direct bonsoir
virginie alors la découverte de la
quasi-totalité du magot renforce la
thèse de l'action d'un homme seul oui
effectivement mari en fait cette course
en solitaire pourrait-on dire c'est à la
fois la force et la faiblesse de toni
musulin
puisque comme l'expliqué le procureur de
la république seul il a pu préparer
consciencieusement son projet le mûrir
dans le temps mais au moment de la fuite
est bien cette solitude est devenu un
handicap
le butin était lourd à gérer le fait
simplement de le cacher si près du lieu
du vol et est en soi un véritable coup
de poker de même pour lui et le box et
le véhicule dont ils avaient besoin
toni musulin ne pouvait compter que sur
lui-même à partir de là et bien les
pistes se sont plus difficiles à
brouiller évidemment alors maintenant
avec deux millions et demi d'euros dans
ses bagages
toni musulin est il resté dans les
parages où at il finalement passer la
frontière en tout cas et bien sa photo
et largement diffusées à l'étranger
il fait d'ores et déjà l'objet de
recherches de la part d'interpol
merci bien génie pour ces précisions en
direct de lyon
journée difficile dans les transports en
commun de la région parisienne la grève
des conducteurs des rer a et b a été
très suivie un train sur dix seulement
sur certains tronçons la plupart des
usagers avaient pris leurs précautions
mais c'est plutôt l'un comprend
sion qui dominait sur les quais sarah
bernuchon vincent bouffartigue sur les
quais de denfert rochereau ce soir
beaucoup des déconvenues et quelques
heureux c'est vrai presque car hangar ce
soir comme depuis ce matin les rer a et
b se font rares alors forcément le
trajet retour s'annonce compliquée train
d'annoncés on sait pas pendant offert 1
million 800 mille personnes en train de
cuisiner chaque jour alors pour faire
face des métro supplémentaires
mais la meilleure solution comme comme
tout le monde la débrouille
je vais gagner bourg-la-reine ensuite
prendre le bus pour regagner chez moi
motif de la grève des revendications
salariales sur la ligne e à
quant à la baie il s'agit d'un problème
d'organisation du travail
pas toujours facile à accepter pour les
usagers je me fais pas de leur mouvement
bien sûr ils ont leurs raisons je ne
sais pas laquelle mais voilà nous aussi
on existe donc on aimerait bien pouvoir
entre la raison
le trafic devrait reprendre demain matin
sur l'une des deux lignes l'aa
quant à l'abbé les perturbations
continuent
et justement en direct de la station
denfert rochereau on retrouve valérie le
rouge bonsoir valérie alors la direction
et les syndicats se sont parlé
aujourd'hui
pour autant le conflit pourrait se
prolonger demain où il se prolongera
effectivement mais sur une seule des
deux lignes la ligne b du rer celle qui
traverse l'île de france du nord vers le
sud est qui dessert les aéroports
parisiens notamment les syndicats se
sont bien retrouvés que la direction les
négociations se sont poursuivies et ne
sont pas interrompues précise la
direction
pourtant il n'y a pas de calendrier de
négociations ni de prochaines réunions
de fixer alors les syndicats décideront
demain matin en assemblée générale de la
suite à donner à leur mouvement
en attendant un galet 800 mille usagers
de la ligne b devront se contenter d'un
train sur deux demain c'est un peu mieux
qu'aujourd'hui mais le trafic sera
totalement interrompue entre la gare du
nord et denfert-rochereau comme
aujourd'hui les usagers de la ligne laon
plus de chance la grève prend fin demain
matin à 7 heures et le trafic
redeviendra normale dans la journée
merci materi pour ces précisions
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est aussi
l'ouverture à angers du procès d'un
plus jugé pour viols agressions
sexuelles ou tentatives d'enlèvement sur
mineurs la dernière victime est une
petite fille de 6 ans elle avait été
retrouvée grâce à la première
expérimentation du système alerte
enlèvement ce matin l'auteur présumé a
dit regretter profondément ses actes
hakim abdel khaleq al ain darrigrand il
se dit hanté par les regrets dominique
guillouche est accusé d'agression
sexuelle de viol et de tentative
d'enlèvement sur 18 mineures tellement
que je souhaiterais la peine de mort
jugé également son ex épouse alfréda
deneux déficiente mentale accusé
d'agressions sexuelles sur quatre
petites filles parmi leurs victimes
aurélia enlevé sur le parking de son
école elle est à l'origine de la
première expérience d' alerte enlèvement
en moins de 24 heures le portrait robot
du ravisseur est publié dans les médias
dominique guillouche sous pression
l'ibère l'enfant son épouse le dénonce
le couple avoue alors avoir déjà violé
ou agressé sexuellement une dizaine de
mineurs avec leur arrestation
c'est la fin d'une longue dérive en
valeur et du du bonheur de les avoir
arrêtées ce couple ce couple diabolique
et il fallait que ça s'arrête un jour
et beaucoup de victimes depuis quatre
ans il ya plus de victimes dominique
guillouche explique qu'il voulait un
enfant à la maison un jouet dit il pour
compenser ces problèmes sexuels avec sa
femme le procès doit durer cinq semaines
le couple encourt jusqu'à 30 ans de
prison
la deuxième vague de la campagne de
vaccination contre la grippe a comme en
ce jeudi après les personnels de santé
ce sont les nourrissons et les sujets à
risque qui sont concernés les centres
d'accueil sont actuellement mises en
place dans tous les départements
comme vous le voyez ici en région
parisienne ouragans meurtriers en
amérique centrale le passage de ida au
salvador hier a fait au moins 130 morts
60 disparus et 7 milles sans abri
l'ouragan se dirige maintenant vers les
côtes sud des états unis mais perd de sa
puissance
les alertes cycloniques ont été levées
pour la louisiane et la floride
c'est tout simplement un score mémorable
5 par touffes le match très attendu
entre lyon et marseille hier soir s'est
terminé sur un scénario incroyable une
avalanche de buts que la ligue 1 n'avait
plus connu depuis 25 ans des attaquants
en pleine réussite et des défenseurs qui
inquiète
aaron ainsi 5,5
vous ne rêvez pas il hier à gerland le
match entre les deux olympiques a
atteint des sommets riche en émotions et
en but dès la 3e minute pjanic ouvre le
score pour lyon
le début d'une folle course-poursuite
diawara égalise le choc tient déjà
toutes ses promesses quand sidney govou
fait cavalier seul dans la défense de
l'om il on repasse devant
mais juste avant la pause sur cette
frappe de cheyrou loris le gardien
lyonnais laissent échapper le ballon de
partout au retour des vestiaires
marseille creuse l'écart but de baky
koné puis du brésilien brandao 4 à 2 à
dix minutes de la fin
les marseillais quoi tenir la victoire
mais le lion est loin d'être mort
lisandro marque deux fois ils renfort
pour l'om
bastos donne l'avantagé aux lyonnais 5-4
et ce n'est pas fini
ultime rebondissement dans les arrêts de
jeu marseille arrachent le match nul 5
partout la fin d'un match aussi
incroyable qu'inoubliable le monde au
rendez-vous pour personne le roman qui a
obtenu le prix femina 2009 son auteur
est une jeune femme qui évoque dans son
roman la souffrance psychologique de son
père à 38 ans gwenaëlle aubry philosophe
de formation et déjà auteur de plusieurs
romans et plusieurs récits voilà pour
l'essentiel de l'actualité en france ce
soir tout de suite on repart pour berlin
pour la suite des célébrations des 20
ans de la chute du mur avec vous david
pujadas on attend alors avec impatience
maintenant le point d'orgue des
festivités la chute symbolique de mille
dominos géants en polystyrène installés
sur une portion de 1 kilomètre et demi
de murs david c'est à vous
oui marine 9 novembre 1989 9 novembre
nous allons donc nous attarder sur cette
journée qui a marqué l'allemagne qui a
marqué berlin qui a marqué toute
l'europe également c'est toutes
dernières images en direct vous voyez
que les préparatifs effectivement son
vraiment très engagé pour ce qui est le
clou vous l'avez dit de cette soirée on
enlève les goupilles des dominos pour
qu'ils puissent tomber les uns sur les
autres dans un effet qu'on connaît bien
avec des petits domino d'habitude cette
fois la seule différence c'est qu'ils
font deux mètres cinquante de haut et il
figure d'une certaine manière
symboliquement ce mur de berlin qui
courait sur 155 km ici à berlin alors
juste avant est ce qu'on a le temps
d'écouter angela merkel s'est tout de
même sa journée à angela merkel c'est
elle qui a voulu lui donner ce faste ce
lustre et puis c'est aussi l on l'a
entendu qui épouse un peu l'histoire de
ces deux allemagnes puisqu'elle a grandi
à l'est avant ensuite de devenir
chancelière à l'ouest alors nous n'avons
qu'angela merkel
on va rester sur le direct l'homme qui
va donner le coup d'envoi de cette
attraction de l'attraction de cette
soirée
eh bien il a été indirectement à
l'origine de la chute du mur c'est les
cheveux les arts l'ancien président
polonais et surtout l'ancien
un fondateur est l'un des fondateur de
solidarnosc ce syndicat qui a ébranlé
l'état polonais et tout le bloc de l'est
avec lui les cheveux les arts sous son
parapluie est prêt il y a avec lui un
un ancien dirigeant hongrois et ce sera
dans quelques secondes peut-être que
nous avons le temps de retrouver sa
masse ou là qui se trouve à côté de ces
dominos hama est ce que la foule est
impatiente
oui david la foule est impatiente elle
est compacte elle résiste à cette pluie
glaciale tout le monde attend ce ce
premier la chute de ce premier domino
qui est un peu le premier coup de pioche
dans le dans le rideau de fer alors
effectivement on a enlevé les groupies
qui maintiennent ces dominos et il y a
des enfants maintenant qu'ils ont
participé à la peinture de ces dominos
qui les tiennent pour être sûr qu'un
coup de vent ne balaie pas les dominos
avant l'heure alors il ya ici beaucoup
de beaucoup de gens beaucoup d'étrangers
qui ont fait le voyage pour être là
aujourd'hui
il y a ceux qui étaient là il y a 20 ans
il ya ceux qui n'ont pas connu qui n'ont
pas assisté à ce fameux 9 novembre 89 et
qui voulait être là ce soir un peu comme
une session de rattrapage on a le
sentiment que vingt ans après on a envie
de revivre on reprend conscience pour la
deuxième génération de ce qu'a été la
chute du mur de berlin dont qu'on attend
d'une minute à l'autre la chute du
premier docu de dominos qui devrait se
dérouler de l'autre côté de l'aj prêt
qui est un peu la scène qui traverse
berlin miller et une précision encore il
ya mille dominos total répartis en trois
tronçons et sur chacun de ces dominos
ont été peintes des figures ont été
aussi graves et des inscriptions par des
artistes allemands par des artistes
venus de toute l'europe y compris des
français qui travaillent ici à
l'institut français de berlin
voilà c'est un un événement hautement
symbolique pour cette journée de
commémoration de la chute du mur de
berlin nous aurons peut-être le temps de
retrouver philippe rochot un autre
endroit de berlin
en attendant et pas n'importe quel
endroit et philippe ce n'est pas
n'importe quelle histoire non plus que
vous nous racontez vous étiez
correspondant d'antenne 2 à l'époque en
allemagne au moment de la chute du mur
et vous vous trouvez à l'endroit même où
vous étiez ce 9 novembre 1989
je voudrais vous poser une question un
peu personnel comment avez-vous ressenti
cette journée du 2 1989 et cette journée
de 2009
écoutez bien sûr très émouvant parce que
ça faisait 15 ans que j'étais pas à
retourner à berlin moi j'ai encore en
tête ce fameux jour cette soirée du 9
novembre 89
nous étions en train d'effectuer un
reportage sur les médecins et les
infirmières d'allemagne de l'est qui
fuyait à l'est qui figure à l'ouest par
la tchécoslovaquie et par la hongrie et
puis à 19 heures donc on a appris que le
mur de berlin allait s'ouvrir
donc nous sommes allés directement ou
métro de berlin pour interroger les gens
les gens ne savaient pas et nous avons
appris j'ai appris à une femme que le
mur était ouvert et donc elle me dit
mais j'ai mon mari qui est de l'autre
côté depuis deux ans je n'ai pas vu
depuis deux ans ça veut dire que je vais
pouvoir le retrouver
donc pour nous c'était vraiment un
événement extraordinaire de quoi
annoncer ou berlinois de l'est qu'ils
allaient pouvoir passer le mur et que
leur après tout s'est enchaîné
nous sommes allés à bornholmerstrasse
est là aussi j'ai rencontré un homme qui
passait avec un petit bébé et qui me dit
regardez c'est le plus jeune enfant qui
va passer le mur de berlin
filmé le et nous avons suivi cette foule
moi j'ai dû repasser par checkpoint
charlie parce que à l'époque encore les
gens des étrangers devaient passer par
cet endroit par checkpoint charlie
pour les diffuser notre reportage à
berlin ouest parce que les techniciens
de l'est de la télévision est allemande
ne voulait pas envoyer notre reportage
sur paris parce qu'il s'apprêtait à
passer de l'autre côté à l'ouest
donc voyez c'est à ce prix là finalement
qu' on a réussi à envoyer nos
témoignages et des images sur la chute
du mur de berlin
alors bien sûr checkpoint charlie ça
reste cet endroit historique
oui
philippe our voulez vous offrir un petit
cadeau et c'est un clin d'oeil à doter
les spectateurs on va la découvrir cette
image c'est tout simplement votre image
il y a vingt ans tout juste alors que
vous étiez devant le mur
est-ce qu'on peut la voir est-ce qu'on
peut la voir cette image philippe rochot
il ya 20 ans tout juste est acceptée non
pas le 9 novembre
mais deux jours plus tard alors que
rostropovitch une honnête son fameux
concert de violoncelle au pied du mur
on ne vous a pas perçu philippe mais on
peut dire que si la ville a beaucoup
changé
et bien vous n'avez pas changé voilà les
applaudissements c'était un des temps
forts de ces jours là au moment de la
chute du mur
michel meyer est avec nous michel meyer
lui aussi ancien correspondant d'antenne
2 à l'époque à bonn un vous n'étiez pas
à berlin évidemment c'était bonne la
capitale de la république fédérale
d'allemagne
michel meyer qui a écrit récemment
l'histoire secrète de la chute du mur de
berlin le voici ce livre aux éditions
odile jacob ou vous raconter un peu les
coulisses et notamment comment ça c'est
ce qui a amené finalement la chute du
mur
mais alors qu'on attend d'un instant à
l'autre cette chute des dominos je
voudrais simplement vous nous disiez
michel meyer vous ce que vous ressentez
vous avez suivi
tous ces événements de très près égale
bien je ressens ce que je ressentais à
cet endroit il y a plus de 20 ans et
presque 25 ans nous sommes à un endroit
qui à l'époque était le symbole de l'
équilibre de la terreur
et lorsque je l'approché est bien ce
n'était pas une kermesse
c'était un endroit glacial et je
ressentais systématiquement un frisson
glacial
c'était pas de la peur c'était une
extrême vigilance et une véritable
poussée d'arnaud d'adrénaline
bien entendu je ne regrette pas cette
époque et je n'ai pas envie aujourd'hui
de ressentir ou poussées d'adrénaline
comparables voilà voilà ce que je
ressens profondément
nous étions ici dans un lieu où
on sentait la tension est-ouest l'on
sentait que les deux allemagnes rivales
étaient des champs de bataille potentiel
d'une déflagration est-ouest
éventuellement nucléaire donc voilà
voilà voilà ce que résume je ressens
aujourd'hui par rapport à cette époque
qu'il n'a rien à voir on attend c'est
une kermesse il ya des fous joyeux
vive la vie alors justement est-ce que
d'après vous les allemands sont
passionnés par cette commémoration ou
est ce qu'il y a un peu d'un différend
sont finalement trouve ça normal parce
que cette séparation s'est fait qu'une
parenthèse je crois que c'est ambivalent
je crois que les autorités essaient de
positiver par rapport à la situation
d'il ya dix ans et même qu'il ya vingt
ans mais en réalité le soleil les
allemands de l'est se sont un peu les
parents pauvres
aujourd'hui encore de la réunification
ils ont dû tout réapprendre à manger à
penser et même à monter des escaliers
nous distille à l inverse les allemands
de l'ouest trouve que les allemands des
sont sont un peu ingrat parce que les
allemands de l'ouest
il faut quand même le dire pendant près
de 12 ans ils ont payé 7 % d'impôts de
plus par an pour faire remonter la rda
et e.on en milliards d'euros et 1300
milliards d'euros au total
c'est tout à fait considérable cela dit
j'y reviens j'y reviens à 50 mètres
derrière où il y a il y à il ya 20 ans
il y avait un mur anti char de trois
mètres d'épaisseur et et ce mur anti
char c'était la ligne de démarcation là
encore d'une déflagration potentiel on
est mis aujourd'hui quand même et les
querelles allemand de comme on dit que
je viens d'évoquer
c'est vraiment des querelles d'enfant
gâté 1 enfin oui alors en attendant la
chute en cascade de ses de cette
première série de dominos avec lech
walesa on va écouter donc je disais
celle dont c'est la journée aussi c'est
elle qui a voulu vraiment faire de cette
journée
ce qu'elle est ce soir c'est un gala
merkel on n'a pas entendu tout à l'heure
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
son intervention
on garde l'image en direct sur les
dominos ce serait dommage de les manquer
on écoutait angela merkel
ce jour-là a débuté une époque d'unités
de droits et de libertés dans toute
l'allemagne et dans toute l'europe
c'est ce qui fait de ce 9 novembre une
très grande journée de joie pour nous
tous
n'oublions jamais le 9 novembre 89e' les
sacrifices qui ont rendu possible la
chute du mur
l'amitié entre les peuples des deux
côtés de l'atlantique ne devra jamais
être rompu ensemble essayons de
maintenir allumée la flamme de la
liberté pour tous ceux qui vivent dans
les ténèbres de la terreur afin qu'ils
gardent espoir
voilà déclaration barack obama il n'a
pas fait le déplacement c'est hillary
clinton
on l'a aperçu tout à l'heure ça
secrétaire d'état qui est ici à berlin
ce soir mais finalement barack obama a
décidé ça n'était pas prévu d'envoyer ce
message dont nous venons d'entendre un
extrait il a été diffusée ici derrière
moi place de brandebourg
1 c'est ici que sont massés des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui attendent
maintenant comme nous nous attendons
cette chute des dominos qui va vraiment
marqué parce qu'en plus on est à
quelques minutes près au moment même où
ces dizaines de milliers d'allemands
le 9 novembre 1989 se sont rués près du
mur et ont réussi à passer la frontière
michel meyer 7 ostalgie dont on parle
parfois c'est à dire la nostalgie pour
les symboles de l'ess on voit que dans
les sondages à quelques % d'allemands
qui regrette aussi cette période c'est
du folklore ou c'est une réalité qui est
lié à une déception pas du folklore ça
traduit dans les sondages où le ressenti
des anciens apparatchiks et des
laissés-pour-compte d'europe de l'est
qui pratique une nostalgie un peu grise
dans les recoins de berlin c'est
important ça existe bien entendu mais il
faut pas y accorder
importance excessive car par ailleurs à
part les problèmes que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure de frustration réciproque
nous sommes vraiment dans un pays qui
sans connaître l'opulence des trente
glorieuses et économiquement néanmoins
très confortable voilà lech walesa est
en train de répondre aux interviews nos
confrères abandonné le avant de donner
le coup de pouce qui fera tout basculer
et nous avons en profiter pour retrouver
en duplex de francfort le
franco-allemand peut-être le plus
célèbre de france il s'agit de daniel
cohn bendit pour soir daniel cohn bendit
merci d'être avec nous quelle image vous
vous gardez de cette journée du 9
novembre 89 et celle que vous venez de
vivre peut-être à travers la télévision
du 9 novembre 2009 et la façon dont
l'allemagne fête cette cette date
je voudrais reprendre quelque chose de
michel meyer je crois qu'il a tout à
fait raison quand il a parlé de l'
angoisse et moi je trouve que le 9
novembre dans l'histoire allemande
ce sont deux dates et qui décrivent
l'allemagne et son ambiguïté ses
contradictions
c'est le 9 novembre 38 c'est ce qu'on
appelle les nazis appelle la nuit de
cristal c'est les programmes contre les
juifs à berlin et c'est le 9 novembre
2009 c'est la libération
c'est une partie de l'allemagne qui se
libèrent et ces deux histoires se
télescopent en permanence dans l'idée
tient dans l'identité allemande et moi
le 9 novembre 2009
eh bien j'ai j'ai assisté en direct à
ceux à cette chose extraordinaire ce
porte parole du gouvernement monsieur
schabowski qui au détour d'une question
en fait à la fin cherche ses papiers ne
les trouve plus est dit et bien voilà le
mur est ouvert et personne ne savait le
9 novembre comment l'histoire allait se
terminer
le matin ceux qui prétendent que le
matin il avait une intuition que quelque
chose allait se passer ne disent pas la
vérité personne ne pouvait le savoir
et ça s'est terminé comme ça dans le
chaos d'un pouvoir communiste
incapable de gérer les choses et qui a
laissé faire si on veut qui a dû laisser
faire
et c'est ça qu'on ait vécu le 9 novembre
c'est cette histoire chaotique et un peu
c'était même un veau de vie qui s'est
passé à la 20 daniel cohn bendit une
question sur le présent sur ces dizaines
de milliers d'allemands qui assistent à
ces cérémonies sur ces millions sans
doute qu'ils assistent aussi face à leur
téléviseur en france y ait un débat sur
l'identité nationale est-ce que 20 ans
après la souveraineté l'unité retrouvée
de l'allemagne il y a aussi ce débat là
du côté des allemands oui mais vous
savez autant en france ce débat si ce
qu'ils ont en france il n'y a pas de
réponse à l'identité nationale autant il
n'y a pas de réponse en france comme ça
c'est du baratin et en allemagne
parce que par exemple bien un homme
politique de droite amie liz de
l'intégration de la cdo qui dit il est
temps de faire en allemagne
la troisième unification y parle de la
nécessité d'intégrer dans la nation les
7 à 8 millions d'émigrés je veux dire
l'identité allemande justement est
quelque chose de fragile et des
allemands différents la définisse de
manière différente
y'a pas une définition je crois que les
allemands de par leur histoire sont
fragiles et je crois que les français de
par leur histoire leur histoire
différente sont aussi fragiles et tout
tentative de définir comme ça l'identité
nationale dans une europe qui est en
train de se construire et quelque chose
d'après moi de contre-productif voilà si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 tout
juste passé d'une minute maintenant et
nous sommes en direct ici devant la
porte de brandebourg au lieu de berlin
où doit se dérouler dans quelques
instants ce qui marquera alors quelque
sorte l'apothéose de ces cérémonies de
commémoration de la chute du mur à
savoir la chute des dominos qui sont
censés représenter symboliquement ce mur
de berlin on garde un oeil sur l'image
en direct et nous allons en france car
en france aussi on a célébré cette
journée on a célébré cette date 7 et
place de la concorde
tout à l'heure et c'est un portage de
jeff vite inverse
les façades classées de la place de la
concorde à billets des graffitis du mur
de berlin
le décor est en place un air célèbre
s'élève la sarabande de la deuxième
suite de bach jouée il y a vingt ans au
pied du mur par le virtuose 8 c'est la
grosse trop politique plusieurs milliers
de personnes se sont rassemblées pour
l'histoire et le symbole il fallait
venir parce que c'est un moment
historique vraiment important pour nous
pour ma génération c'est la libération
d'un peuple qui était quand même
oppressé après la guerre et tout et ce
mur qui est comme ça et on devrait
appeler tenir les murs dans le monde
devant les officiels 27 violoncellistes
ont maintenant pris place dans autant de
stèles représentant des pans du mur de
berlin s'interrompt car c'est parti pour
les dominos avec une petite rupture de
faisceau pour nos amis de la télévision
allemande comme ça tombe mal
mais les dominos c'est parti s'écroule
comme dans les jeux
ces mille dominos qui sont autant de
petites oeuvres d'art signées d'artistes
de toute l'europe et notamment
d'artistes allemands et bien lech walesa
le premier qui a osé dans les années 80
défié la dictature communiste c'était en
pologne vient de donner le coup de pouce
qui les a faits s'ébranler qui les a
fait tomber aussi vite que le mur est
tombé sur 9 novembre 1989 lorsque des
dizaines de milliers d'allemands se sont
pressées devant les points de passage et
qu'ils ont forcé ce passage devant
l'hésitation du régime est-allemand
pendant ce temps les vivats de la foule
et bien c'est fait pour cette première
série de vidéos visiblement ça soulève
un enthousiasme bon enfant ça m'a saoulé
vous êtes en direct ça ma wii de bide
il ya beaucoup de bruit autour de moi
maintenant les et domino oui il est
dominant la mer les applaudissements de
la foule et ben en fait il n'y a pas eu
de quoi qu'ils sont tombés d'un seul
trait sous les applaudissements et les
hourras leur volaille c'est un amas de
petits dominos mur symbolique ce mur
éphémère depuis trois jours à berlin est
tombé remontant encore la rumeur qui
continue maintenant de l'autre côté
puisque les les dominos vont tomber de
votre côté
du côté de la porte de brandebourg
davila vous allez perdre votre voix
samoa est ce que le spectacle est à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils avaient suscitées
parce qu'on parlait depuis plusieurs
jours de ces dominos écoutez d'avis
depuis plusieurs jours effectivement on
attendait la chute de ces données
et qu'ils ne sont en fait que le point
d'orgue de toutes ces semaines de
préparation pour les allemands on a
beaucoup travaillé dans les écoles on a
beaucoup parlé de cette rda de de tout
le système de la stasi les écoles ont
fait des programmes spéciaux et nous
mêmes qui avons travaillé ici
ces dernières semaines pour préparer un
certain nombre de reportages mais en
cours de ces deux de ses reportages de
ses voyages nous nous sommes rendu
compte à quel point ce passé avait
marqué les allemands et ce qui nous a
particulièrement touché marqué c'est que
j'ai le sentiment que vingt ans après il
ya des dossiers qui ressorte un peu
comme si juste après la chute du mur les
allemands de l'est était tellement
pressé de 2,2 d'être comme ceux de
l'ouest qu'on a un petit peu occulté se
passer cette jeunesse qui ont pour
certains malgré la dictature était des
années heureuses s'était il faut le
rappeler leur jeunesse et vingt ans
après et bien les longues
un peu comme si les langues se délier
pour parler
de cette période et les vingt ans au
point d'armes comme si c'était un peu
une autre réunification a posteriori
avec peut-être pour les allemands de
l'est une fierté retrouvée d'être ceux
qui l'ont été et ce qu'ils ont pu
réaliser depuis ces vingt dernières
années
oui en tout cas c'est une très belle
mise en scène que ces dominos et on a vu
que ça a suscité aussi l'émotion chez
plusieurs des personnes qui étaient
présentes ici on a vu on a vu des yeux
embués d'émotion et c'est normal c'est
vrai que ça figure assez parfaitement
parce qu a été la chute du mur il ya 20
ans j'ai aussi envie de demander son
sentiment à quelqu'un qui vient de me
rejoindre
le docteur andreas langue de bois
pendant que nous continuons à découvrir
ces images
alors pourquoi nous vous avons invités
docteur est bien parce que ce 9 novembre
votre femme était sur le point
d'accoucher vous habitez berlin ouest ou
l'emmener à l'hôpital
et puis les médecins vous dise
finalement ça n'est pas pour tout de
suite vous reportez vous entendez
lachlan heures vous savez ce qui est en
train de se passer et vous dites je sens
au sens propre du terme
les allemands de l'est arriver expliqué
nous et bien c'était pas tout à fait
comme ça parce que déjà quand j'ai
appelé ma femme à l'hôpital
j'avais déjà eu les dernières nouvelles
à la télévision on avait entendu le mur
est ouvert mais je n'avais pas le temps
d'aller voir directement
donc je suis allée avec ma femme et
contrôleur
arrivés près de l'hôpital sur un
carrefour tout d'un coup c'est ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure je sentais
l'odeur des voitures travail itt il
avait une odeur caractéristique là par
une voiture est-allemande qu'il ya un
mois leurs caractéristiques comme vous
le dites et donc une odeur de gasoil
caractéristiques te ment et donc je
disais à ma femme
mais ils sont déjà là c'est déjà arrivé
alors qu'on venait de l'écouter encore à
la télévision vous en avez vu ce soir
des allemands de l'est avaient franchi
le nul qu'ils faisaient là on s'est
arrêté dans un carrefour et nous ont
demandé mais comment on peut aller aux
courses en dame
oui le coût d'un nu et je leur ai dit et
bien voilà c'est vous êtes ou tout près
il n'ya plus que sur 100 m il vous
demande est en quelque sorte leur chemin
voilà il voulait savoir où le cochon
dames ce sont les champs-elysées de
berlin et voilà c'était donc cette
première rencontre quand le 17 mai les
imagine c'est un souvenir inoubliable et
le lendemain et le lendemain je suis
retenu hors est retourné au mur avec
notre fils qui avait disons aux gens on
est arrivé directement ici à la porte de
brandebourg et il y avait donc des
foules qui était déjà sur le mur et des
gens qui étaient en train de me voler vu
il ya quelques secondes voilà voilà de
détruire un petit morceau de mur
certains pour en garder un petit bout
certains tout simplement pour se
défouler après vingt ans derrière le mur
voilà et c'était exactement notre
sentiment c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'impensable on n'aurait jamais pu
imaginer que ce jour à l'air est arrivé
et il y avait il y avait un jour tu mens
des triomphes comme le port la pierre
est intéressant vous lis tu y avait un
sentiment de triomphe on revient sur
l'image en direct parce qu'il ya une
autre série de dominos qui va bientôt
maintenant tombé au sol
il y avait un sentiment de triomphe
est-ce que vingt ans après ce sentiment
nous triomphe est toujours là d'une
certaine manière je dirai ce que les
espoirs ont été réels
où est-ce qu'ils sont un peu déçus ou
quelques étés alouettes se rappelle
jacques à l'ouest donc je dois dire goût
de ma part ce n'est certainement pas été
déçu parce que pour nous aussi nous
avons gagné une forme de liberté
chaque fois qu'on quittait verlan été
obligé de passer par la frontière et
c'était toujours une petite forme
d'humiliation
on savait qu'ils les policiers de l'est
pouvait alain portes moment n'importe
quel moment nous arrêter si on avait dit
quelque chose qui n'était pas tout à
fait comme il fallait et c'est donc non
je ne suis pas pas du tout déçu pas du
tout et je crois que même c'est quelque
chose d'unique convient dans une vie que
tout d'un coup une situation se
transforme
oui complètement de noir en blanc c'est
vrai que c est qu est ce qui nous donne
de l'espoir pour beaucoup de digne de
situation personne n'avait prévu
effectivement encore une fois que la
chute du mur que la réunification serait
aussi soudaine je crois qu'on va
retrouver sa masse ou là qui a peut-être
à ses côtés certains de ceux qui sont
venus fêter ses 20 ans cet anniversaire
de la chute du mur ça ma wii david en
fait la population commence à se
disperser mais il ya avec moi un jeune
homme qui s'est baladé tous ces derniers
jours à berlin avec cette pancarte il
est français il s'appelle etienne il a
20 ans tu peux venir et il s'est baladé
avec cette affiche nous sommes tous des
berlinois donc etienne pourquoi être
venu assisté aux 20 ans de la chute
alors en fait moi je suis né deux jours
après la chute du mur de berlin est un
intellectuel qui s'appelle fukuyama qui
a écrit que le chute du mur de berlin
c'était la fin de l'histoire et ça fait
quelque chose de jours après la fin de
l'histoire
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
cette chute du mur vous qu'il y avait 20
ans et qui ne l'avait pas connu disons
que pour moi c'est c'est la création
d'une nouvelle europe
l'europe telle que j'ai toujours connu
en fait cette europe dans laquelle je
peux voyager totalement librement
sansan sans aucun souci croissance en
dictateurs sont personnes pour
m'empêcher de d'aller où je veux comme
je veux
merci voilà david à présent les les
dominos sont au sol certaines personnes
ont voulu passer les barrières pour
marquer leur trace dessus pouvoir écrire
mais apparemment ce n'est pas possible
nous attendons après la chute des
derniers domino à présent un feu
d'artifice et ensuite des concerts pour
terminer cette nuit a dû du 9 novembre
voilà et ben on la souhaite très belle
cette nuit c'était un journal en direct
de berlin un soir de fête pour ses 20
ans de la chute du mur alors comme
toujours une édition direct dans ces
conditions c'est un peu bousculé nous
n'avons pas passer tout ce que nous
voulions vous faire voir où vous faire
entendre
mais ce sera pour les éditions qui
viennent et pardon à ceux que nous
avions invité et qui n'ont pas pu parler
c'est maintenant l'heure de rendre
l'antenne au programme c'est la fin de
cette édition
merci donc à vous d'avoir suivi tout tu
sais la météo de nathalie rihouet il va
faire aussi froid qu'en allemagne ce
n'est pas peu dire
20h35 cold case affaires classées à
22h15 mots croisés avec yves calvi sujet
l'identité nationale justement ils vont
parler avec ses invités yves calvi
toutes les équipes techniques
éditoriales de france 2 ont été
heureuses de vous présenter cette
édition spéciale à demain à paris et on
se quitte pour le plaisir avec
quelques-unes des plus belles images de
cette journée est de cette soirée à
demain merci
et
cette tragédie osant perdu dans nos
m
quoi